hey guys Colossians 3 verse 2 says set
your mind on the things above not on the
things of Earth you know if you do that
it changes your whole life
I think they'll go agrees look
do you agree
it changes everything because you know
you can argue about the silliest things
with your family
I cannot believe that there are so many
Christians who call themselves
Christians and still they don't forgive
their family members
Jesus said that you have to forgive them
if you don't want to forgive them then
he's not going to forgive you
and how can you not forgive them after
what Jesus did for you
all the things that he forgave you
set your mind on the things above think
about the Eternal things and not the
temporary and love the people around you
remember that always